Prince Harry's son you've heard by now
his name is Archie is only a few days
old but he's already getting some baby
swag the new dad received this adorable
little onesie this morning and an event
promoting his Invictus games as Invictus
games mean a lot to Harry Archie is the
first member of the royal family to be
eligible for US citizenship that's
because of his mom Megan Markel and
that's not the only difference
mts tyub is in Windsor England where the
new family lives and he has lots of
people have things to say about baby
Archie they definitely do and a lot of
people really like his name but I got to
tell you gal the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex Harry and Megan decided really
early on in their relationship that they
were gonna do things differently and the
introduction of their son to the world
is no different it was a beaming Prince
Harry who was cradling his newborn son
as he was introduced to the world he was
easy
sleepy well good baby yes
in the past we've mostly seen royal
mothers holding their tightly wrapped
little bundles of joy like here with
Kate and Princess Diana Diana was very
protective about William and Harry and
and had them swaddled in a old-fashioned
lace blanket
so you Coney could see that just like
the tops of their heads and when Kate
appeared with Prince George he was
equally swaddled a heart to see infant
might have been in keeping with
tradition revealing his name on
Instagram was not Archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor which is far less of
a mouthful than most traditional royal
names which tend to be much longer
Colleen Harris of former royal press
secretary says it's no surprise the
youngest member of the royal family is
already unlike most others the first
mixed heritage child in the British
royal family and I think that is
significant it's a whole new chapter for
a group in British society that are sort
of neglected expect a lot of attention
paid to how the new parents choose to
raise their firstborn Harry's mother
Princess Diana tried hard to make sure
he and his brother William could
experience something of a normal
childhood outside the royal bubble says
Tesio Joe who oversees the Diana award
charity one of the things that she did
as a mother
is she still divinely have all values
into them into her songs I have no doubt
whatsoever that does values we passed on
to this baby now as we've been learning
Harry and Megan have decided to forego a
courtesy title for their newborn son but
this is interesting when Prince Charles
his grandfather becomes King little
Archie will become Prince Archie Norah
what is interesting in Tia's tie and in
Windsor thank you very much I like the
name Archie I like it very much
I think it's friendly but I think it's
also very substantial and I loved that
it wasn't on anybody's list so people
are very surprised that they
chose a name that no one didn't that
nobody saw coming nobody saw coming